[Music]
she's got 38 million dollars to be exact
thanks to her TV shows Vegas residency
and numerous endorsements JLo comes in
at number 65 on the Forbes celebrity 100
list which is out today and all the
Divas are there Katie Brittney RiRi and
Adele who earned a whopping 69 million
dollars just by touring but last year's
number one artist Taylor made a swift
drop to number 49 Taylor Swift was at
170 million dollars last year this year
she's down to 44 that's not because
she's suddenly become irrelevant it's
because she stopped touring to Capri
just feel like I'm more comfortable on
stage than I am off stage and paid off
for the Biebs who took in the biggest
haul of his career last year eighty
three and a half million dollars putting
him at number 13 on the list he's got a
ton of hits out and he's been able to
channel that into making a ton of money
on the road so who made the top 5
Drake is number 4 and beyonce is number
2 her formation tour grossed over a
quarter of a billion dollars it feels
good to know that the hard work paid off
beyonce way out her husband jay-z who
pulled in only 44 million on the past
year you look at jay-z and Beyonce in
terms of net worth they say that over a
billion dollars as a couple so you know
they could earn nothing for the next
couple of years and just travel the
world and I think the GRS but topping
them all at number one Diddy
his bad-boy family reunion tour Ciroc
liquor brand and the sale of his Sean
John clothing line earned him one
hundred and thirty million dollars last
year and his advice for success just
have fun and don't stop
[Music]
you